a small desert town just southwest of
las vegas feels a little bit bigger
tonight getting something that they
desperately needed can you imagine we're
talking about this in 2022 neighbors in
sandy valley now have a gas station the
town as you see here located about an
hour from where we are in las vegas off
the 15 in jean christian casadas took a
drive there to find out what this means
to not only those who live there but
also to visitors
you don't go over the hill if you got
less than a quarter tank that's the way
it's been delano sturgeon can't stop
smiling about this gas station he says
it's his town's newest hot spot and also
his peace of mind i got gas cans at home
i usually try to keep full for
emergencies you know generator because
we get a lot of power outages and stuff
the two pump unleaded fueling station on
the corner of quartz and mojave will be
a major asset to the town of about 2
thousand according to one of the
investors luke mostaler they're hoping
to to sell about between 25 and 30 000
gallons a month
that would be about 58 phillips a day
this gas station has a very unique
system because as you can see everything
is above ground now the owner tells me
the idea stems from a very personal
challenge mustalar says his elderly
mother who still drives is the reason
behind this project the portable fueling
tank costing a fraction of a traditional
gas station and it also makes it easier
to replace or add different fuel for
drivers without leaving the area this is
great this is great i wish they had
diesel because i got a diesel pickup
but but all my jeeps regular sandy
valley also seeing its share of visitors
from las vegas and southern california
looking to explore off the beaten path
now without worrying about an empty tank
christian casa is live local now
investors of the gas station are hoping
to add another location in perramp the
site they say can also be modified to
charge electric vehicles if needed